everyone who auditioned for any of the
different roles of victoria's had the
same sides
tori and trina throwing down a secret
matthews sibling and vicki's
mysteriously missing little brother
ah what could have been if these scenes
hadn't been deleted
disney and nickelodeon shows seem
perfect as they are but a lot of them
were almost
entirely different from characters being
deleted completely in shows like wizards
of waverly place
to an entirely different beginning to
victorious that started off the whole
series with an epic fight
but would these moments have made our
favorite shows even better
or should we be happy they ended up on
the cutting room floor
let's find out well soon
tori and trina have always had a
complicated relationship
that's why things in victorious almost
got off to a very violent
albeit hilarious start the pilot was
supposed to kick off with a fight
between the two sisters
until they decided to leave their
sibling rivalry to be discovered a
little bit later
before the play she and trina were
fighting we were arguing
the whole series was originally supposed
to start with a flashback of tori and
trina singing
i don't need anything but you from annie
when they were only seven and eight
years old
near the end of the number trina hits
tori in the face and knocks her over
perfectly setting up their dynamic
throughout the series the scene was
completely shot but never made it into
the episode
thankfully there are plenty of other
moments where the vega sisters fight it
out before
ultimately making up it's not because i
think you're a bad actor
duh esteban julio ricardo montoya de la
rosa ramirez
is not only our favorite bellhop but he
also has one of the best names of any
disney channel character
it's no wonder that the suite life of
zack and cody needed to give him some
uber famous parents to go with his
iconic name
you may have noticed that spanish
superstar charo played his mother when
esteban got married on suite life on
deck
mommy i am sorry but you are not going
to stop this wedding
i am going to marry my francesca no but
his father was supposed to be the one
and only george lopez
according to actor adrian armante lopez
had the part and was ready to go
but then he backed out last minute they
brought in charo to give esteban's
family some flair
but we like to imagine that george lopez
is still his dear old dad
can i have it i do i do
before nathan cress was freddie benson
on icarly
he played an uncredited kid in the
battle of panthatar episode of drake and
josh
you can see him in the background for a
few scenes however he originally had a
much bigger role in the episode that
involved him hitting on miranda cosgrove
and that's the best revenge there is
nathan's character was supposed to
repeatedly hit on megan and follow her
around during the episode
but it was actually getting the role of
freddie and icarly that got his part in
drake and josh cut
series creator dan schneider wanted
freddy to have a crush on carly
but that wouldn't be fresh if nathan and
miranda were already hitting it off on
another show
so nathan got all of his lines cut but
he also got to star in a super
successful nickelodeon show
cue the random dancing if i do we kiss
me no
then no we know vicky has a little
sister named tutti
in the fairly oddparents but did you
know that she was also supposed to have
a little brother
in the pilot she mentions her younger
sibling it works great at my house
just ask my little brother
but then she never speaks of him again
series creator butch hartman even joked
did vicky do something to him
we definitely wouldn't put it past her
hartman also shared some early ideas for
the show with 17. originally
mom and dad turner were supposed to be
like some of the adults in the powerpuff
girls
and not have faces but constantly hiding
their heads got too complicated
so the turner parents became the crazy
couple we know and love
we'll need a dog to get rid of it you go
and get one on the unaired girl meets
world pilot that still hasn't been
released
riley matthews was supposed to have an
older brother named elliot
played by t o helm the casting news had
already gotten out by the time it was
reported that due to creative
differences
tio wouldn't be appearing on the show
after all another switch up in the cast
happened when sabrina carpenter
and rowan blanchard completely switched
roles sabrina originally auditioned for
riley and i originally auditioned for
maya and then
we swapped about two auditions and the
rest is matthew's family history
more character change-ups happened in
wizards of waverly place
justin russo was supposed to have a best
friend played by sunny with a chance
star brandon michael smith
for what it's worth you threw a cool
problem sonny there was also a recurring
character named rachel
who was played by jonas star chelsea
kane while brandon ended up never
appearing in the show
leaving us without the wizards and sunny
crossover we never even knew we needed
chelsea did end up guest starring as
carrie langsdorf in the baseball episode
oh i only date baseball players and i
only see movies about baseball
no cats remember when drake bell made
our middle school hearts flutter when he
guest starred as himself on the spring
fling episode of zoe 101
well it turns out that we almost got an
epic duet out of the episode
paul butcher who played little bro
dustin told 17 that he joined drake bell
on stage for a performance that was
filmed but never aired
paul went on to say it was one of his
favorite memories from being on set
we're sure we would have loved it too
because it turns out that that kid can
really sing
when you think of mysterious nickelodeon
characters drake and josh's mom probably
doesn't make the cut
but seriously this iconic tv mom is full
of secrets
oh hi i'm drake's mom you're his mother
yeah
is something wrong her character name on
imdb is listed as audrey parker nichols
even though her name was never actually
said on the show we also never found out
about her
job but all of these secrets were about
to be revealed in the series final
episode
dan schneider said he wrote one line for
the finale that went something like this
hey audrey how's your catering business
going ultimately schneider decided not
to use the line
and keep the joke running long after the
show had wrapped hannah montana had to
cut one messy scene
after parents told the disney channel
that it was inappropriate in the episode
where miley and lily learn oliver has
diabetes
hannah's nasally friend tracy van horn
was supposed to get covered head to toe
in chocolate after miley and lily yank a
tablecloth to get the sugar away from
oliver
the entire scene was filmed and actress
romy dames said she smelled like
chocolate for days but because they
didn't want to offend anyone
disney cut the scene and rami's
chocolate bath never made it to tv
you are adorable it turns out that ned's
declassified school survival guide's
coconut head
has been hiding some pretty big secrets
in that hair of his
actor rob pinkston told 17 that there
was supposed to be a big reveal in the
final episode that would have seen
coconut head reveal his true name
and get a haircut rob also shared some
info on the original
pilot where another actor played coconut
head and singer jojo played lisa zemo
cookie didn't even appear in the
original plot vanessa's my dream girl
but
i don't want to hurt lisa's feelings
part of the reason lizzie mcguire is so
iconic is because we got to see her name
listed on our tv
every day after school but her pesky
little brother played by
jake thomas shared a juicy piece of info
that might have changed
everything it turns out that the show's
original title was
what's lizzy thinking that title totally
makes sense
since we get to see inside lizzie's head
in the form of her animated alter ego
my once-in-a-lifetime chance is going to
come around but naming the show after
lizzie helped make her the feminist icon
we all looked up to when we were young
before it was liv and maddie it was
called bits and pieces and it was about
one girl named alana
and not a set of twins dove cameron
revealed that they filmed the pilot
and got feedback before the studio
decided that the show should be about
twins
dove was thrown into the middle of
things and had to take on the role with
barely any warning
put a love note from a secret admirer in
her locker and she'll forget all about
joey
that's actually a really good idea she
even considered leaving the show but
thankfully she stuck around and pulled
off playing the iconic sisters
still we'd love to see that original
pilot episode
every year my sister luanne creates a
prank apocalypse and no one is spared
loud house's lewin can definitely take
things too far
like she did in one april fools episode
where the showrunners felt like they had
to cut
a very long and devious prank she
surrounds lincoln with cups of water
while he sleeps when he wakes up
he finds that every inch of his floor is
covered so he decides to drink his way
out
unfortunately he finds out the hallway
is also full of cups of water
after drinking it all the real prank is
revealed he can't get into the bathroom
to rid himself of all that liquid
not cool lewin not cool cameron boyce
was spectacular
and we all know it originally luke was
supposed to be named hero
and have a totally different backstory
coming from korea but disney loved
cameron so much during auditions
that they decided to completely rewrite
the character for him so he could be on
the show
i've got this face a c plus average and
two coats of deodorant
he was the best and only choice for the
role annelise vanderpool who plays
chelsea in that so raven was almost the
star of another disney channel original
annelise actually landed the role of kim
possible and was totally down for the
show
until she also landed a part in that so
raven
because it was live action she decided
to go with raven's house instead of the
possible family
christy carlson romano went on to voice
kim but we would have loved to see some
sort of crossover episode
which of these deleted moments is your
favorite let us know in the comments
down below which scenes you wish they
kept and which ones you're happy they
cut
don't forget to hit that like button and
subscribe to the things for more
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]
you